uh my name is jay mccarthy i'm happy to
be here with you at strange loop it's
very odd for me to not be presenting a
research talk just about something that
you know just kind of old that i know a
lot about it's also weird to be
teaching you something old and not
preparing to give you a grade on it
that i hope that you'll enjoy and you'll
learn something as well
my talk is called continuations on the
web and
in your operating system i've got three
major things that we'll be talking about
first what are continuations
i assume that most of you maybe have
heard continuations but
you know like monads you know just being
an endo functor in the category of
monoid you know what i mean like
just knowing what the definition of a
continuation is
is not really useful for knowing why
they're useful so i'll really
dig deep into what a continuation is and
in particular what delimited
continuations are
i'll talk about their classic uses on
the web and then i'll talk about more
exotic uses of continuations
so to start off with what is a
continuation
the continuation the classical
definition
is the rest of the computation meaning
that at any given point in a program the
continuation
is all the things that will happen in
the program
after this piece of the program is done
for instance
if we look at this computation here this
beautiful program with four five six
seven eight and nine my favorite numbers
and addition multiplication subtraction
my favorite operators so this program
right here results in a negative 27
not my favorite number but it'll do if
we zero in on that
subtraction right there we can ask what
is the
what is the continuation of this piece
of the program
and every piece of the program has a
continuation no matter what programming
language you're using
the continuation of this piece of the
program is
everything outside of that little box
this
new box represents the continuation and
that dark box
is where the answer from the sort of
current program the subtraction will go
after it's done uh if you're
uncomfortable with bananas we can
convert to
a more buttery c-like syntax and look at
this program which is really the same
program
and i've highlighted the same expression
the subtraction
and here the continuation is also the
rest of the computation what will happen
when this piece of the program is done
so it's this little thing right here
typically in
you know these old-fashioned languages
with this kind of syntax
it's a little bit more obvious what the
continuation is
so going back to banana world though
this continuation right here
is just a mental concept that we can
have as programmers
of what's happening in our program we
could represent this
inside of the language as a function so
for instance
uh in racket i can write it like this so
first of all i find the lambda button on
my keyboard and i hit that
and now i've got a function which
encapsulates or represents
the behavior of the continuation of that
subtraction so we have the lambda that
takes in a z
and uses that z in the same context that
the black box used to be in
so this right here is a continuation
that we're not running so that's why the
result is just the procedure
so in a language so you can always
every programming language every piece
of the program has a continuation
in some languages you can represent that
as a function particularly when there
are first class functions available
in a language like racket that
representation
can be done automatically for you
through a function
called in bracket it's called let cc so
what let's cc does right here
notice that it's it takes the place of
that box that i had before
so let's see see k says name the
continuation
that function which i showed you before
name it k
now as you all know the word
continuation starts with the letter k
of course it doesn't but we name it k
because of tradition there's this famous
thing called the cesk machine
which is a formalism and k stands for
continuation and c
stands for code and since c was already
taken we had to find another letter
and so we use k now anyways so what this
program does right here
is it simply names the continuation and
the beautiful thing about names is that
once you have them you can start using
them all over the place
so we can ask the question what happens
when we actually use this name
so for instance here i've changed the
program
to name the continuation k subtracts
7 from 6 getting negative 1 and then
call
k with it and notice that the result is
a question mark because this is a test
so do you think that the answer to this
is
uh negative 27 or do you think the
answer to this is something else
remember negative 27 is what it was
before um
where you know when we send negative 1
here we multiply it by 5 and 8 and then
we add in the 13
or does that negative 27 which the whole
program used to return
go back in to the multiply and then go
in through the plus again so it's either
a really big negative number
or a really small negative number the
really big negative number would be a
thousand
sixty-seven and the small negative
number would be negative twenty-seven
well to find the answer to this we have
to go back to what i told you was the
representation of the continuation
i told you it was this but actually i
lied to you
because the program the future of the
computation
is not just the multiply in the addition
it's actually
your program ending and then printing
out the result so in reality the future
of the computation contains this call to
exit right here
because if you look at the whole future
of your program they all eventually
end at least we hope that they do and
because we don't normally want infinite
loops
so what that means is that when we call
the continuation like this
it's not like dropping in the whole
program again right there so that it
will go out again
it's more like dropping in the program
including that little exit
and since that exit is there the program
does not run
twice it just runs once
so this is of course what the actual
result of that let's cc is
so it's important to be able to
recognize that in this sense
continuations
are undelimited which means that they
they typically
take represent the entire future of the
program
including the exit in a language like
racket
we have the ability to name a place
at which the continuation will stop
stop being named so that's called a with
prompt so with prompt is a way to say
the continuation shall go this far and
no further
and so here i've put the with prompt
around
the exit or right before the exit then
when i use
let cp which is a version of let cc that
is the delimited version
this continuation k here only captures
the multiply in the plus it does not
capture the exit
therefore the answer is the negative 67.
so these are just the basics of using
continuations
now continuations are one of those
fairly complicated things where
there are really strange consequences to
this semantics for them
so for instance after we call k
and observe our own future we can then
behave differently and multiply it by
two so this program
inside of the sub right before the
subtract
it looks at what its future is sends a
negative one there
gets the answer back and then multiplies
it by two before going to the future
again
it gets to sort of relive history which
is really the future from its
perspective
which is very odd we can in fact do
even more weird things like going to the
future multiple times of course we were
already going to the future multiple
times but
now we're going to the future a third
time where we go to the future with
negative 1
come back with that negative 27 multiply
by two and then go out again
and now we get a giant uh negative
number you know
85 867 that's actually my favorite
number
which is why i chose negative 27 in the
first place
so anyways we can do even more bizarre
things like saying well
what if i send a negative 1 to the
future is that going to be positive
if it is going to be positive then i
really do want to send that negative 1
otherwise i'll send a 0. and since
the answer ends up being negative 27
it's not positive so we send the zero
thus the the full answer is you know
five times zero times eight which is
zero
and then we add four and nine and get
the 13. so we're observing our own
future and then doing something
different based on that behavior
but of course this is all delimited by
that with prompt
so our actual future might end up
returning a positive number for instance
if we were to multiply by negative 1
outside of the with prompt so here with
prompt is sort of like a
veil over the future that we can't see
beyond
and so continuations and particularly
delimited continuations in this way
have uh surprising answers sometimes
now this all probably just seems really
bizarre um
which is why we're going to stop
twiddling with continuations and we're
going to look at some of their uses
particularly on the web but to summarize
continuations represent the future of a
computation
they themselves can be represented as
functions and they come in different
varieties
unlimited underlimited ones which are
the entire future
and delimited ones which are the future
up to a point
finally languages like racket give you
all these
wide varieties and many in very few
languages give you all these options
so let's go on to how they're used on
the web
if we look at a really simple command
line program like this
this is the add to numbers.exe so
first it's going to prompt for the first
number then it's going to prompt for the
second number
then after that it will add the two
numbers and print out the answer
so we start writing this it says enter
first number i type in 2
then 0 then it tells me enter the second
number then i type in 2 and 2 and it
gives me the sum is 42 which is all our
favorite number right
now if we were to try to convert this
program into a web application
it's not as simple as just saying well
web printf
that you know uses angular brackets and
web prompt which you know puts in a form
or something like that
we all know that it's not as simple to
do this and the main reason is that
because http
is stateless whenever you send a
response to a request
you're not allowed to wait for another
response that is semantically connected
to the first request which means that
every time you send
a question out on the web you have to in
addition to sending
the question tell the user where they
should send the answer to
this is why web pages contain you know
the url that the form will go to or the
url
that links will go to as well that's a
way of telling the client
where they should send their answer so
when you were if you were to write this
in a normal
web environment you would do something
like build a dispatching table that says
if you go to the url slash
then we're going to prompt enter the
first number and we're going to tell the
user that they should send the answer to
slash sum
and then put their answer afterwards in
the url then if you were to come to
slash sum and it would be 20
then you say okay that you know that
matches this the way that this url looks
so i'm going to parse
out that first and say well give me the
second number and
go on back to us with you know slash sum
slash
22 20. then at that point the third case
in the dispatcher
would take over and then we'd be able to
actually add them up
and print them out so most web
applications
that focus on server interaction like
this look like this where the programmer
has to manually split up
all the control flow of their
application into discrete steps which
correspond to urls
and useful web frameworks
like ruby on rails and that sort of
thing make it really easy to
bind functions to urls but they don't do
anything to help us
take the control flow structure and map
that onto a set of urls that's something
that we need to do as programmers
typically
but what we're doing here is we're
actually
manually turning our program into have
explicit continuations
for instance if we were to say well
continuation one
receives the first answer and
in when we first start the program we
web prompt
and we go to enter first number and we
say well the answer should go to
continuation one
and then inside of continuation one we
prompt for the second number and say go
to continuation two
and then in continuation two we actually
have both numbers now when we add them
so this process of manually transforming
programs
into their continuity their explicit
continuation version
is something that web programmers have
done for a very long time
but of course if we were in a language
that gave us the ability to
automatically know what the continuation
were
then we could build a new kind of web
server
that could implement web prompt directly
so here is
more or less the actual implementation
of web prompt
from the racket web server which does
this the first thing that we do
is we capture the continuation on the
server
which is the future of the server's
computation
then we store that continuation in a
dispatching table just like
normal dispatching tables map urls to
functions
this storing gives us back a new url and
then we send
that url out to on the web page so it
would say like the form should go here
and now when the web when the web client
comes back
it executes that continuation as opposed
to one of the top level functions that
we wrote to begin with
so this is more or less exactly how the
racket web server works
at least on the servlet side if we were
to look at how
the server works oh there's a lot more
details
and i would suggest that you look at
some of my research papers and oops law
icfp
or the higher order symbolic computation
paper if you are interested in more of
those details particularly on how to
make it
really efficient to do this so if we
were to look at how the web server
itself works though
the web server is really a function that
takes in some servlet which is
seen as something that transforms http
requests
into http responses and how it works is
it sort of runs in an infinite loop this
is one of the infinite loops we like by
the way a network server
and then it will wait for a connection
once the connection is available it'll
wait for a request
once the request is around it gives the
request to the servlet which is supposed
to return an answer
then once it has the answer it displays
that out to the connection
now of course because of http 1.1 you
know there could be multiple connections
but stuff like that is not really that
interesting
the more interesting thing comes from
how this works
with the continuations so for instance
if we go back and we look at the
implementation of web prompt
we capture this continuation here and
notice that it's an
undelimited continuation which means
that it goes all the way to the exit
which means that the continuation of the
servlet
includes the behavior of the server
including the behavior of sending the
answer back
and since continuations know what their
lexical context is
it would actually if you made a request
on one channel
and then the new request came on the
second one the second handler would try
to send the answer back to the first
request
it would be as if the web server were
written like this where we wait for a
connection connection one
then we have request one and response
one
but by the time we get connection two
and request two request two
refers to the url that is the
continuation
generated by request one so that when
you display the answer for response to
you're actually in request one's future
not request two's future because you've
gone back
in time by calling the continuation thus
tr you you end up trying to send the
response
down a network channel that doesn't
exist anymore so it's essential
when you're using continuations that you
know
where the continuation goes and this is
why delimited continuations are so
important rather than just undelimited
continuations so
this means that the actual
implementation of the web server
puts a prompt around the call to the
servlet
to make sure that any continuations it
captures
only go back to the servlet
and there's one more thing which is that
this send to client idea is actually
something that continuation prompts
allow as well continuation prompts
specify the area
allow you to represent the continuation
back to that
that point but in addition they allow
you to sort of be like an exception
handler and throw a value back there and
that's called aborting
the current continuation where you send
a value back to that point
you can think of it like an exception
handler but actually it's technically
more accurate to think of exception
handlers as being continuation aborts
where you can represent an exception
handler as whenever you
say what the handler is that's really a
prompt and then exceptions are aborting
back to that prompt
so that's enough about obvious oh yeah
there's just a few little details that
actually
it's really important that prompts are
first-class citizens there's not just
one prompt
it's important for there to be many many
prompts that can be dynamically
generated
so that different uses of continuations
for different purposes
don't interact poorly with one another
so
now we'll get to the sort of more
complicated stuff
okay so the first thing is more
complicated ways
of using continuations on the web
so the first idea is that is called web
components so right here this is a
little bit of a dense
uh piece of code that's using the actual
functions available on the racket web
server so what this does is it calls
send suspend dispatch which gives you a
function called
embed url what embed url does is it
transforms functions into urls that call
those functions
when the function returns it returns to
the same place since it's been
dispatched would have returned to
so what this program does right here is
it has two links
the first link says first and the second
link says second and when you click on
them it changes what the header is
so the header starts off as something
when you click on first
it becomes first then you click on
second it becomes second the more
interesting
thing though is where it says right here
include counter so include counter is
this other function
that's going to drop in
two more links one to a subtraction
button and one to an addition button
and what these buttons do is they
control the value of a counter that's
being stored in this web component
now the thing that's interesting about
this is that the first thing that
include counter does
is it captures the continuation of its
caller
that means that include counter captures
a continuation which represents a future
in which a web page is being generated
and being sent back to the user
and this web page that's being generated
is one that includes a header
and every time you interact with the
addition or the subtraction link it
loops back around to the beginning of
include counter
where it returns a different value a
different html page
to its um parent to its caller so this
is almost like a server sided iframe
where you have a totally sealed off
piece of interaction
inside of a much larger piece of action
piece of interaction
through the use of continuations to
capture that context
so this is a really simple example but
there are more complicated ones that
would actually be valuable that are not
just inserting counters into programs
but none of those fit on the slide so
let's look at one more thing
so another more advanced use of
continuations is
in event-based network servers so for
instance if we look at a typical
network server it would look a lot like
that web server that i showed before
where you know
you have some file descriptor where you
read a request then you read another one
you'll compute some answer involving
those generate a response
send the answer back and then free some
resources
so if you know anything about network
servers you will look at this and you'll
say this must be terrible and the reason
it must be terrible
is that this read request right here
it's likely to block
meaning that as it's waiting for more
network packets to arrive the whole
program
is frozen waiting for this to return so
it's far more advantageous to use
non-blocking interactions like epoll or
kq or something like that
but when you use those things you have
to
transform your program into one where
you have made explicit what the events
what the events are and what should
happen afterwards so if you know
node.js node.js is programmed this way
and it exposes that programming model to
you
so here's a little simple example of an
event loop where we have a list of
events
and we're going to synchronize on them
and we'll return one of the events that
succeeds
that's available that means like the
network packet has arrived
and then each event in our formalism
will receive a function
that it can call with whatever new
events
it generates when it succeeds and what
it's going to do is it's going to return
it's going to call itself again with
whatever the new events are
so we can represent that old network
server by calling event loop
by starting it off with a list that will
handle
the read request event and generate a
request to
request one i'm sorry and then these
four dot dot dots if we zoom in there
what we do after we've successfully
read the first request is we generate a
new request
sorry a new event that will read the
second request
if we zoom in on these dot dots again
we can now finally compute the response
and we can generate an event that is
waiting to send the answer back
and when that event succeeds and the
answer has been fully sent we can then
finally free the resources
and notice that next empty we're now
done with this sequence of events
so we can throw this away so this style
of network
of event-based network servers is widely
used in c
programs that are based on epoll when
you use epoll you have to explicitly
break up your code into each step of the
continuation
when you're programming in javascript
because you can't make
long-running actions you have to break
up your code and put it in between
timeouts basically so you say you sort
of have a zero timeout that does some
work and then sets a new zero time out
so all these ways of breaking your code
up with asynchronous interactions
are all indications that you're manually
producing continuations
now if our language supports
continuations then we could write a
version of read request
that captured our context realized what
its continuation was
and then generated an event and sort of
sent it off to the event loop and said
you know go wait until this is done and
when it's ready call this continuation
and so this style
of masking blocking calls
over non-blocking interfaces is really
what a threading system does
when i say threading system i mean a
cooperative threading system
a threading system that's provided by
the operating system truly has blocking
in it
but one that's provided on top so called
green threads or user level threads
will hide these blocking operations
as non-blocking ones and essentially
what what the threading piece does
is it will capture the context of that
thread which
is its continuation so if we zero in on
this idea a little bit more
we can talk about how delimited
continuations are really used
inside of operating systems because
operating systems
are little more than threading systems
where the threads of course are the
procedures however
there's one more thing that operating
systems do but we'll talk about that in
a moment
so here is a complete implementation of
a threading system using continuations
in about you know 12 lines so we have a
list of threads which is initially empty
when you spawn a thread you just add it
to the end
of the list of threads when you want to
switch threads
if there are any available meaning that
the thread list is not empty
then you'll grab that first one and
you'll you know replace the list of
threads
with the rest and then you'll call that
next function which
performs the computation that is the
next step of some thread
and if you are a thread and you want to
yield you capture your continuation
spawn it as a new thread and then call
switch so that somebody else can take
over
so this right here is honest to goodness
a complete implementation of a threading
system
that you can write and racket and here
is a little program
so we have a looper that will run
a loop five times and every time it will
print out a number
and then it will yield after each print
and then at the very end it will switch
so if you spawn this into
one looper and then you call looper the
two will run back and forth between one
another
and it'll print out zero zero one one
two two three three four four
and then it's over because they both
only go through five times
so this is obviously not an interesting
program and
it really just shows that delimited
continuations allow you to express
threading very simply
and since threading is at the core of
operating systems it gives us a view
on what else operating systems have and
the other thing that operating systems
have other than of course booting off
the hardware which is very boring
is that they have system calls and what
are system calls
system calls are access to sensitive
resources of the operating system
here we have a structure that represents
a kernel where you have
the list of threads which is the
concurrency provided by the operating
system
and here we have a safe and the safe
represents
any volatile resources that the
operating system manages
you know it manages the hardware it
manages the file system
all these resources of the kernel it's
its job is just to be the sole
master of them to protect you from user
programs
so we'll we'll write a little operating
system that's just protecting one
thing called the safe so here's the
little program that we'll
write in our operating system and so
what this one does it has two loops
and it calls this function swap i hope
that the
the two loops look very simple to you
they'll go through
five times or seven and five and they'll
print something out but the interesting
thing is that they call this swap
function
and swap will be the system call that
our operating system provides
it's kind of like a rendezvous where
what it does is it allows you to install
a value into the safe
and then read out what's currently in
the safe and so these two functions
as they run they swap values back and
forth with one another printing out what
their current value is and what the
value installed by the other guy was
so if we look at how this is how this
operating system would be implemented
we first define this boot function that
starts off with an initial kernel
the initial kernel just has the main
program and
zero in the safe and it's gonna loop
forever until there's no more threads
and then each time it loops around it's
going to step
one thread up to one system call
to step one thread we figure out
whatever the top thread is
we run that thread until we reach a
system call now that we have this system
call that says whatever they want to do
we'll execute that system call on a new
representation of the kernel state
and return that back to the bootloop
which is going to go all through it
again
so what is a system call a system call
is a data structure
that represents one a user context and
then
two whatever the operation is and its
arguments
so when you spawn a thread you need to
know what the child is
when you end there's really no
parameters obviously in unix you have a
number that you return
and with our special operating system we
have swap which has the new value that
you'll go inside of the safe
so this representation of system calls
is really
just like how system calls work in a
real operating system
because a system call is represented by
a number which is kind of like its type
tag
plus some meaning given to the other
arguments available to the interrupt
handlers
so if we look at how to execute a system
call in our operating system
when we're spawning a new thread we
create a new kernel state
that has the user context the child
context and what all the threads were
before
when we're ending we just forget what
the user context is because this pro
this thread is gone and when we swap
if you look at the last line we put the
new value of the safe
inside of the kernel and the interesting
thing is how we represent
returning values to the user context the
user context is a continuation which
means it's a function that you can call
we've always assumed that these
functions don't take any values but in
here we're going to return whatever the
current value of the safe is put that
back on the thread queue and let things
go on
so we have to ask ourselves how do we
generate these system calls
and the way that we do it if we were to
look at one system call like thread
is it takes some parameters and the
first thing it should do is it should
capture
its continuation which is the
continuation of this thread
that corresponds to like its stack and
what its registers are
really what it the future of that
computation is and we'll call that the
user context
and then we'll abort or throw a data
structure which stores the user context
and the arguments to this thread
back to the kernel and of course we want
to have one of these for each system
call and so since we're in a language
since we're in racket we'll write a
macro that generates one of these
functions for each one
of the system calls that are available
so now we've got these functions for
each one
so this these are the throwers and so
the one thing we haven't seen is the
catchers how does the
operating system catch these system
calls
and the way that it does it is by just
installing a continuation prompt
calling whatever the code was for the
thread and then
waiting for it to be thrown the place
where we wait for it to be thrown is
very opaque in this uh code example but
it's actually this
word values right here so this function
right here is where you write down what
you want to happen
when a value is thrown to a prompt
and what we want here is to have that be
returned which in racket is a function
called values
so what putting all this together we
have a
full operating system with system calls
in 50 lines of code
you notice but these are all just the
lines that i showed you before and this
is 50 lines of code that implements
a threading system and a protected
kernel
with a system call for interacting with
the safe scarce resources of that kernel
since this is just 50 lines that's very
very general you can use this to create
domain specific operating systems that
specialize
in the various operations that they
provide it really provides a new
paradigm
for protecting resources we normally
think of protecting resources through
things like moan ads
which seal them off through a type
system or locks which protect them
through
stopping things from interacting but
operating systems for a very long time
have had a master
child or master servant relationship
between
dealing with scarce resources and so
this supervisor supervisee
relationship is something that a
domain-specific operation operating
system like this provides
and it's beautiful to me that we can
provide it in just 50 lines of
simple racket code that uses the limited
continuations simple of course if you
know what delimited continuations do and
what they are
so at this time i'd be happy to take
questions about anything that we've
talked about
or anything else that you know or care
about related to continuations thank you
regarding your web server um it's kind
of abstract so
yes it's hard to see all the details but
um are all the requests self-contained
so that every all of the state is
basically in the client
and your you know the server gets all
the contacts back to the url or you
it's implicit there that you're doing
some session state for the cookie or
i mean that wasn't clear to me yes so
the question is um
are requests self-contained uh it is
everything on the client or is there a
session state that's stored in something
like a cookie
so a a continuation represents
the um the control flow of your
application
a session cookie is more like
the heap so when two threads are
interacting they both have different
control states
but they have a single data state that
they're sharing so
cookies are not the correct way to
understand the interaction between
multiple pieces of an application so
that's why for instance
cookies are valuable for representing
things like shopping carts which
multiple page views
are both modifying but they're not
useful for keeping track of where you
are on two different sequences
so because of that so that's one thing
so the next thing is whether or not
continuations are
entirely stored on the client or whether
they're
stored on the server and on the
able to pick client yep yep i understand
so
with the racket web server it's possible
to fit anywhere in the spectrum
if you want you can store everything on
the server or move everything to the
client
there are certain resources that cannot
be shared with clients so for instance
a continuation may contain a reference
to a file descriptor
there's no way to turn a file descriptor
into something that a client can store
what you can do is you can give the
client a name which refers to a file
descriptor but ultimately the file
scripter needs to remain on the server
so these foreign objects that cannot be
serialized
are inherently necessary to be stored on
the server
and the racket web server allows you to
specify
when you want those to be allowed when
you want them to be stored if you want
things like that to even be possible or
if you'd prefer to error when it tries
to serialize that sort of thing
so those research papers that i cited
before talk about the ways that we
deal with things that are on the server
versus on the client obviously it's
valuable for things to be on the client
but it's much more complicated to have a
serializable representation of a
continuation
given that continuations are these like
closures
most closures in most languages are not
serializable so it's difficult
to do that but yes any other questions i
can answer for you
yes uh i've been seeing
uh posts about delimited continuations
in
other languages like scholar do they
work the same way
yeah so um if you read a scala's page on
delimited continuations they'll talk
about how
they're inspired by the icfp paper that
i studied before
and so they specifically target some of
the research that we've done in racket
in their implementation i would not
classify myself as an expert on exactly
how
scala implements its continuations but
my understanding is that
it has many of the beautiful things
about them
seem to be one of those things that a
lot of people study somewhere along the
way
but it seems like they don't get a lot
of use
in the idea why um so the question is
continuation seem like something that
people study a lot but they
don't get a lot of use i think that
people do in fact use them a lot
it's just a matter of whether they use
them implementing them themselves or
implementing them or having the language
provided for you
so for instance almost every javascript
program that uses
an ajax request is using continuations
it's just a matter of whether those can
whether they know that they're doing
that
and whether they are informed and sort
of
improved in them in themselves by that
experience of knowing that
and so i think that the point of this
talk is that
once given that continuations are widely
used
in a sort of an amateur sense if you
understand the details of them you may
unlock new potential for how you could
use them and i'm also
saying that it would be nice if more
languages like scala were to
imitate racket by having delimited
continuations
in their fullest sense
i would say that one thing is that maybe
continuations particularly on the web
are associated with ancient web
applications um
that are not like the glitzy web 2.0
ones but nevertheless
uh they still have the same uses
uh they are still useful in modern web
applications just so all the papers
refer to these old style so i think
that's something that's definitely
relevant
for sort of the pr image of
continuations
anything else
yes
he gave about the enclosure async
libraries because
it seemed like we started that out with
piles of uh to be the kind of
control flow machine can you explain if
there's an
you know advantage that you may not have
mentioned about
using like sure so yeah so
uh the question is did i see richie's
talk on asynchronous
and in particular on the downsides of
using piles of functions for managing
asynchrony
so i think that rich and i agree that
using piles of functions for asynchrony
is very bad
because it's complicated to keep track
of what the control flow state is
and one way to avoid that is by
switching to the concurrent ml
style of asynchrony that he talked about
but another way to avoid that is by
having your language
produce those quote piles of functions
for you automatically so you can write
the straight line code
that is easier to understand and have an
expert the compiler produce the piles of
functions
for you there's nothing wrong
necessarily with the model
of asynchrony that delimited
continuations for instance use the main
problem
is in the cognitive overhead of having
to do that yourself
the things that compilers do humans
could do but we have compilers do them
because it makes our brains hurt what's
the
is there a fundamental tradeoff between
those two models
um i think that there are different
models of concurrency
uh concurrent ml okay so
i think maybe the answer is that there's
not a dichotomy
between the continuation style of the
asynchrony
and the concurrent ml style of
asynchrony they're both useful for
different situations
and if you'd like to learn more about
this i would suggest reading the
the kill safe servers or kill safe
synchronization paper
by flat and findler that talks about how
concurrent
ml primitives have some problems but
when used in a certain way allow
really expressive forms of asynchrony
and that is in the context of racket
where
you might otherwise assume that the
limited continuation style
would be the one that would be preferred
so i would say that they're really
there's really
no either or between them they're both
useful and that's why
powerful languages like racket have both
and with that we have my awful sound to
say that i'm done thank you so much for
being here
and i will talk to you all later